uh the last time we spoke there were two
comments that you said that stood out to
me well one was the somber the somber
heard around the world in a sense
and then you clarified that or you added
to that by saying sobering oh i was
wondering we can get to that and then
also you mentioned that the charlatans
of the world will be shown to be
charlatans
and i again don't know much about this
ufo community
but people in the comments were saying
did he mean stephen greer
so why don't you comment on that
you can be as diplomatic as you like i
know that you're you're a relatively
diplomatic person yeah let me um
let me start with by by somber sobering
um
imagine
imagine everything you've been taught
whether it's through sunday school or
through regular formal education in
school or
what our political leaders have told us
and yes even maybe our mothers and
fathers around the dinner table have
told us or maybe at bedtime um about
about who we are
right in our background in our past
um
what if
all of that turned out to be
not entirely accurate
in fact
the very history of of our species
um
the meaning what it means to be a human
being and our place in this universe
what if all that is now
in question
what if it turns out that a lot of the
things that we
thought were one way
aren't
are
are we prepared
to have that honest question with
ourselves
are we prepared to
[Music]
to recognize that we're not at the top
of the food chain potentially
that we're not the alpha predator that
we are
um
maybe somewhere in the middle
um
you know it's it's interesting because
i was having discussion with a friend uh
not too long ago really really we call
them graybeards in in the government
really really smart guy i'm not going to
mention his name but but i was talking
to him probably a couple months ago
and this is a guy who was always paid to
solve the hard problems for the us
government cold war how do we solve that
right how do we do these big big things
how do we go in and
and uh and and beat the russians at
their own game um
so this guy i respect tremendously and
and we had a conversation he said you
know lou um
mankind's been around for a little while
and for most of that time mankind's been
around we've been smacking the middle of
the food chain we've been
um you know we we ate a lot of things a
lot of things ate us and that's just the
bottom line
and about 70 000 years ago something
fundamentally changed something changed
and and our species
was instantly catapulted to the very top
of our planet as far as predatory
animals
and um
and now all of a sudden
we became the most feared
um we we we were the most lethal
and the most successful in fact
uh most of the large species that that
that existed on this planet went extinct
because of us believe it or not because
we we
eating all of it
there were a couple species that did
very very well with our ascension our
immediate ascension and we brought a
couple species with us the dog as an
example where the dog species benefited
greatly with mankind's ascension as the
alpha predator and and wanda succeeding
as well very doing very well off of that
that changed the the entire global
landscape of our planet
um almost overnight large animals went
extinct
because of us
what if it turns out that
there's another species
that
is is even even
even higher on the on that on that
ladder than we are
um
[Music]
do we need the social institutions
that we have today will we need
governmental and religious organizations
that we have today
if it turns out that
there is something else or someone else
that is that is technologically more
advanced and and perhaps from an
evolutionary perspective more advanced
um
have we been wasting our time all this
time
or
are we doing exactly what we're supposed
to be doing
um
are we
or are we does it turn out that mankind
is is in fact
just another animal in the zoo
or because we thought ourselves as a
zookeeper before but maybe we're just
another exhibit inside the zoo
what would that mean to us so so when i
say sombering and sobering
uh i mean that it's it you know
there's gonna come a point in this
conversation we're gonna have to do a
lot of reconciling with ourselves
whatever that means from whatever
philosophical background you
you have
this is gonna impact every single one of
us the same and yet equally and yet
differently
um
and i think that's important
um
you know
do we find ourselves in a situation
where history may have to be rewritten
um
so that's what i meant
now as far as the charleston's i'm not
going to give any attention to
individual charlatans because they
already have enough attention they know
exactly who i am referring to
these are individuals who have have have
made a a cottage industry a career of
taking people's hard-earned money and
deceiving them and not only deceiving
them but having them sign
non-disclosure agreements to make sure
they don't tell the world that they've
been deceived
and preying upon people who
who for whatever reason
believe in them
um
uh
people who say
my narrative is the only narrative and
anybody else who tells you otherwise
um you know is trying to hurt you
um i have all the answers i have the
solution
anybody who says that
i think um
i think it's a charlatan
and and i think we need to be very very
mindful of that they're very
dangerous uh and they're dangerous for
several reasons because if they're lying
to you about that they're probably lying
to you about other things in their life
their past life and their current life
which may or may not come to light at
some point
these are people who
who have taken advantage of people for a
very long time
and uh
you know you you have to be careful
you know
what else are the motivations of some of
these charlatans or potentially could be
their motivation other than financial oh
look at any religious charlottesville
it's the same thing it's a cult it's a
cult personality it's somebody
who for whatever reason thinks it's all
about them
and and they manage the narrative it's
it's it goes to the to the basic core of
pride and ego in human beings
and narcissistic behavior
you know real true deep psychological
issues um some sociopathic to be honest
with you
um
is there any gold in that rubble
i'm sorry is there any gold in that
rubble as in is all of what they're
saying some of these charlatans we don't
have to name names i no i think i think
i think there's always there's always
fibers of truth
in in in a blanket of lies
um
because that's that's what holds it
together there are some there are some
aspects of truth the problem is um when
you take that truth and you distort it
you know
there's people in history that
that were very good at convincing large
amounts of people that they have the
answer right um i don't need to go back
into into history to say which ones
those are but you have
characters like jim jones
um heaven's gate is an example um you
know even hitler to some degree where
where
they were
very charismatic people
who who got people in in this this web
and they didn't realize it until it was
too late
and um
you know i just think when you when
you're creating all these shell
organizations and pass-throughs and
paying people off to do things for you
to deceive other people i think is
problematic again i'm not going to say
i'm not going to mention names i i i
think most people are smart enough to
see through it
my concern are those people who who
already already sucked into it it
becomes a cult and becomes brainwashing
and manipulation
and that's my concern because it gives a
terrible name to the to the to the
effort and and making false accusations
um you know i i think is is
there's an old saying and see if i can
remember it that
ye be careful of the knife
ye uses to stab at the back of others
for surely that knife will be used
against you in the future or at some
point so you know um
anyway being just you know right karma
karma is a [ __ ] be careful
you know mother nature has a vote she's
got a way of always squaring things up
at the end and
you know that's that's what i've seen
anyways